Від того, що почалася ця війна навколо "Приватбанку",
програють абсолютно всі.
Пан Коломойський міг і не втратити "Приватбанк".
Якби держава з ним домовилась, я думаю, що це був би win-win.
Як Ви ставитесь до того, що Вас називають міністром без портфеля?
Нормально ставлюсь. Це мовний зворот.
Чи доводилось Вам пережити якусь поразку, чи то невдачу, у боротьбі з бюрократією.
Всі мої поразки ще попереду.
На ринку побільшає кількість безробітних?
Так, на жаль, так. Ну, це капіталізм.
Реформа держслужби України. Наскільки реально зменшити витрати на держслужбовців,
зробити їхню роботу ефективною та ще й приборкати корупцію.
Про це ми говоримо Дмитром Дубілетом, міністром Кабінету міністрів. Доброго дня.
Доброго дня.
Успішний підприємець, у минулому ІТ-директор "Приватбанку", співвласник"Монобанку"
залишає все, аби піти і працювати міністром Кабінету міністрів з зарплатою 30 тисяч гривень.
Як би Ви поставилися до такого вчинку,  якби йшлося не про Вас?
Все залежить від конкретної особи.
Я можу собі уявити когось, хто прийшов сюди заробляти гроші,
чи прийшов сюди на корупційні речі.
Але я знаю багато випадків, в тому числі серед моїх колег-міністрів,
які прийшли сюди явно не для того, щоб заробляти гроші
і, до речі, в багатьох з них не така проста ситуація з грошима.
І в нас зараз точиться дискусія про те, чи можна підвищити зарплату топ-менеджерам,
заступникам міністрів, міністрам, тому що дійсно на ці гроші…
У приватному секторі вони б отримували набагато більше.
У моєму випадку зарплата абсолютно не має значення, тому що я сюди пішов не через гроші.
Завдяки "Монобанку" є можливість певний час існувати без якогось додаткового заробітку.
Мотивація дуже проста. Тут можна робити дуже круті корисні речі.
І в якийсь момент я вирішив, що це буде краще, ніж займатися бізнесом.
Ще у березні 2019 року Ви заперечували можливість найближчим часом піти в українську політику.
Мовляв, хотіли б відбутися як бізнесмен. Що спонукало вас вже у серпні змінити своє рішення?
Ви знаєте, кілька факторів. По-перше,
з того часу "Монобанк" дійсно став приносити прибуток.
І в мене з’явилася можливість один рік, два, три, я не знаю, кілька років точно не думати про гроші.
З іншого боку,
я не знаю, можливо, трохи пафосно прозвучить, у мене враження, що зараз є вікно можливостей.
Я вважаю, що дійсно Україна в змозі зробити такий стрибок.
Ну, насправді, дуже круто бути частиною цієї історії.
Ну, я думаю, що 2 -3 роки тому Ви про українську політику інші речі говорили?
То так, так. До цього якось більш песимістично ставився.
Я вважаю, що дуже багато залежить від того, хто при владі.
У мене дуже великі сподівання, що ті люди, які при владі, вони зможуть. Ну, подивимося.
До речі, я  - один з тих людей. Я дуже сподіваюсь на це.
Як Ви ставитесь до того, що Вас називають "міністром без портфеля"?
Нормально ставлюся, це мовний зворот. Таке…
За два місяці на посаді вже можете чимось похвалитися?
Так. В принципі, дуже багато проектів розпочато, навіть деякі на завершальній стадії.
Ми зараз розпочинаємо таку масштабну перевірку по кількості державних службовців.
Тому ми де-інде зараз оптимізуємось.
Можливо, Ви чули новину про те, що минулого тижня ми оголосили,
що ми районні державні адміністрації скорочуємо на майже 20 тисяч людей.
Державну службу статистики майже на 2000 людей скорочуємо.
Ну, я думаю, в нас будуть ще органи, які мають бути більш оптимальними, більш компактними.
Чому Ви впевнені, що ці люди, які залишаться, будуть працювати ефективніше?
Ми зробили докладний аналіз того, як працюють ті ж самі районні державні адміністрації,
то ми подивилися на ті функції, які взагалі непотрібні або застарілі, де немає чітких вимірювальників,
де йде дублювання з іншими органами,
і ми просто вимушені були порізати саме ті частини, де, з точки зору саме функціоналу,
не з точки зору конкретних людей, потрібно було йти на скорочення.
В майбутньому маємо створити таку систему, щоб кожен державний службовець
мав якісь вимірювальні показники,
за якими його можна оцінювати,
і робити таким чином, що ті,  хто найкращі результати показує, отримують найбільші доходи,
ті , хто працює гірше, вони отримують менше доходів або зовсім замінюються.
Що Ви можете сказати тим держслужбовцям, які чекають не на скорочення,
а на підвищення зарплатні або покращення умов праці.
Тут в Кабміні є не такі красиві кабінети, як у Вас?
До речі, я з цього кабінету також переїжджаю,
я вважаю, що цей кабінет занадто великий, я хочу тут зробити оупен-спейс.
тут можуть досить комфортно сісти близько 30 людей.
Взагалі реформа державної служби, вона, у тому числі, передбачає збільшення зарплат.
Якщо ми будемо зменшувати кількість людей, то ми зможемо тим, хто залишиться,
дати кращі умови, кращу зарплату.
Наша мета - щоб люди отримували принаймні не стільки ж само, як в комерційному секторі,
але  принаймні щоб це було не на порядок нижче.
Ви хочете скоротити кількість держслужбовців на регіональному  рівні.
І Вас критикують за те, що насправді ніяких скорочень не буде.
Просто усім уріжуть ставки, а кількість людей залишиться та ж сама,
як це було багато разів раніше.
Ні, тут саме йдеться про скорочення,
є дуже конкретні підрозділи, департаменти, які ми закриваємо.
Ми вже вручили попередження дуже багатьом людям.
Протягом 1-2 тижнів маємо завершити це по районним держадміністраціям, це 18400 з чимось людей.
І по Державній службі статистики також протягом цього та наступного тижня
ми попереджаємо близько 1770 людей.
Ми зараз працюємо з профспілками,
службою зайнятості, щоб допомогти їм потім знайти своє нове місце в новій економіці.
Якщо ці скорочення відбудуться, то на ринку побільшає безробітних…
Так, на жаль, так.
Теж будуть витрати держбюджету. Який компенсатор?
Компенсатор наступний.
Одна справа, коли ти бачиш, що людина виконує функції,
яка не надає додаткової вартості або додаткової користі для суспільства.
Дійсно, ти йдеш на болючий крок, ти робиш з цієї людини безробітного,
вона отримує  дещо менші гроші у статусі безробітного.
Але з іншого боку, вона отримує шанс знайти нову роботу.
І коли людина знаходить нову роботу,
будемо спродіватися, вона буде соціально корисна або корисною з точки зору ВВП, наприклад,
то таким чином економіка і зростатиме.
Ну, це капіталізм.
Чи вдалося Вам пережити якусь поразку чи-то невдачу у боротьбі з бюрократією, про яку
Ви так наполегливо акцентуєте в своїх дописах в соціальних мережах?
Поки що, якщо переіначити з відомого фільму: всі мої поразки ще попереду.
Тому що ми лише починаємо дуже багато проектів.
Я можу навести такий приклад, от я зараз намагаюся запровадити
електронний документообіг абсолютно по всіх міністерствах,
по всіх центральних органах виконавчої влади,
повністю позбутися усіх папірців,
зробити "реінжиніринг" усіх бізнес-процесів, які кояться тут всередині.
Я можу сказати, цей процес відбувається не так швидко, як хотілося.
Якщо чесно, в мене був досвід впровадження в комерційних структурах, і там воно швидше йде.
А тут навіть в своєму підрозділі, в секретаріаті Кабміну,
я думав, що зроблю це за 1-2 місяці максимум,
а от зараз я дивлюсь, що за 3-4 місяці я повністю все тут зможу перевести в електронну форму.
Ви вмієте добре рахувати.
Скільки тонн паперу чи-то грошей Ви хочете заощадити
на тому, щоб перевести усю роботу Кабміну з паперової на електронну?
Мені рахували колись, чи-то 50, чи-то 100 мільйонів гривень на рік на папери
витрачаютьс по всій вертикалі виконавчої влади.
Але ж тут мовиться не про папір, це не про заощадження на папері.
Тому що коли ти переводиш усе в електронну форму,  це, в першу чергу, про ефективність,
про те, що ти дійсно можеш вимірювати якість роботи людини, про те, що ти можеш
дійно зробити її більш ефективною, більш прозорою.
В тому числі, це менше корупційних ризиків і тд.
Ви ініціюєте скасування медичних довідок.
Чому Ви вважаєте, що
при прийомі на роботу не треба вимагати від держслужбовця довідку від лікаря про стан
його психічного здоров’я чи-то відсутність наркозалежності?
Ну, дивіться. Насправді я поки що цього не пропоную.
Я запропонував суспільству дискусію про те, які довідки потрібні, які ні.
Я, дійсно ,вважаю, що довідка у нарколога, у психолога для людей, які влаштовуються на роботу,
не тільки на держслужбу, будь-де, вони не потрібні.
Тому що на Заході цього немає.
І тобі не потрібно брати довідку на все поспіль для того, щоб людина влаштувалася до тебе на роботу.
Якщо вона виявиться наркоманом, умовно кажучи…
До речі, наркоман купить цю довідку, тобто вона не працює.
Тобто, якщо людина не дає хабарів, якщо він не наркоман, умовно кажучи,
для нього це просто зайва бюрократія.
Система не працює. Тобі потрібно бути реалістом.
Якщо щось не працює, це краще скасувати.
Медична довідка для басейну - звичайно, це питання
можливої купівлі у лікаря. Але як захистити тих,
хто ходить в басейн і є здоровим?
Нема статистики, яка підтверджує, що країни,
ті багато країн, які не мають таких довідок,
мають більший рівень захворювань, ніж Україна.
Ця довідка не працює.
Уявіть собі, що в нас буде, якщо буде довідка для людей, які заходять в метро.
І уявіть собі, що ми її запропонуємо скасувати.
Звісно, буде багато людей, які скажуть: Ви що?!
Я їжджу в метро, там мої діти! Ви що, хочете, щоб ми всі заразилися?
Але, на щастя, в нас в метро немає довідки.
На щастя, ніхто від цього не помирає. Мабуть,
хтось помирає, але суспільство справедливо
вважає, що це була б зайва бюрократія. З басейном те ж саме.
Обов’язкова публікація законів в "Урядовому кур’єрі",
в "Голосі України" не потрібна. Треба все переводити
в електронний формат. Вас критикують за  таку позицію:
мовляв, через те, що це ризиковано.
Закони зможуть змінювати заднім числом.
Як Ви можете гарантувати, що цього не станеться?
На щастя, дуже мало хто критикує, але ідея дуже проста.
Є в нас в Україні така велика штука,
як  електронний цифровий підпис або,
як його зараз називають, "кваліфікований електронний підпис".
От уявіть собі, що у Вас є електронний документ,
ви на нього накладається підпис і публікуєте  на сайті.
Після цього ви вже не зможете нічого зробити з документом
для того,  щоб підпис, умовно кажучи, не злетів.
Тобто  це 100% контроль з боку громадського  суспільства,
з боку всіх, кому це цікаво. Про те,
коли  був оприлюднений документ, який час публікації.
Це гарантія того, що ти не можеш нічого змінити.
Це нормальна міжнародна практика.
На проєкт "держава в смартфоні" гроші в держбюджеті 2020 року
гроші не закладені. Чи означає це, що
такий план ЗеКоманди може бути просто обіцянкою?
Ні, просто в бюджеті нема такої чіткої назви,
як "країна в смартфоні". Тому що "країна в смартфоні" -
це майже всі проекти одночасно. Для того, щоб щось
потрапило у смартфон, треба переосмислити все,
що відбувається в тому чи іншому міністерстві
чи в центральному органі виконавчої влади.
Є багато програм по інформатизації,
є багато програм реформування і так далі.
Тобто "країна в смартфоні" - це не окремий рядок у бюджеті.
Це чи не вся робота, яку ми робимо.
До речі, з іншого боку, є багато донорської допомоги
саме по айтішних проектах, тому насправді багато
грошей ми не закладали в бюджеті, тому що
в нас є попередні домовленості з великими донорами,
з великими нашими західними партнерами,
які підтримують реформу,
тому ми будемо використовувати в тому числі їхні гроші,
за що я дуже вдячний, в тому числі німецьким партнерам.
Яким саме?
Нам німецький уряд теж допомагає.
Розмір  можете оголосити?
Якісь проекти отримують рівень десятків або сотень тисяч євро,
якісь проекти можуть отримувати мільйони.
Часто ця допомога полягає в тому, що ми наймаємо
дуже конкретних спеціалістів,
яким сплачують зарплату міжнародні партнери.
Є дуже багато варіантів співробітництва.
Система "Прозорро" не стала 100-відсотковим інструментом
прозорості державних закупівель. Чи згодні Ви з цим?
Майже не згоден, тому що "ПроЗорро" -
не панацея від корупції чи відкатів,
але саме для прозорості вона стала тією системою,
тому що ми з вами - громадянське суспільство, журналісти, -
ми бачимо абсолютно всі тендери.
Ми бачимо, а чи бачать це ті, хто має на це реагувати?
Я маю на увазі оці приховані схеми,
де  відбуваються дрібні тендери і розпил такий бюджетних коштів.
Я вважаю, що неможливо однією системою
подолати абсолютно всі проблеми.
Звісно, ви абсолютно маєте рацію, що
дуже й дуже багато треба допрацьовувати...
Я презентував концепцію.
Ми хочемо централізувати всі ключові закупівлі,
які є в рамках міністерств.
Починаємо з дуже простих речей. Наприклад, папір,
комп'ютери, канцтовари і так далі.
Замість того, щоб у кожному міністерстві,
у кожному органі  хтось самостійно робив ці закупівлі,
ми все це централізовуємо в одному місці.
Там будуть працювати люди з більш високими зарплатами.
Ці люди будуть проходити тестування на поліграфі раз на рік.
Вони будуть відповідати за те, щоб купляти
все на всі міністерства одночасно. Я думаю, що
завдяки цій реформі ми зможемо дійсно
в тому числі знищити корупцію.
Я справді сподіваюся, що протягом кількох місяців
ми зможемо децентралізувати закупівлі серверного обладнання,
тому що сервери - це завжди найбільші корупційні ризики.
Сервери, ліцензії, бази даних.
Там абсолютно шалені бюджети і зазвичай дуже великі відкати.
Ви зазвичай уникаєте питань про "Приватбанк".
Але одне питання я все-таки поставлю.
Мені цікава Ваша думка не як людини,
безпосередньо причетної до "Приватбанку"
в минулому, а як фахівця в банківській галузі.
Чи були альтернативи націоналізації банку,
чи це було єдино правильне рішення?
Альтернативи, звісно, були. На жаль, так сталося, як сталося.
Які?
Я вважаю, що акціонери та держава могли
домовитися краще і зробити таким чином, щоб
держава не витрачала гроші на націоналізацію
і банк був у нормальному стані.
Хто насправді виграє від масових позовів,
які розглядають в українських та міжнародних судах?
Я не знаю, хто виграє. Я знаю, що абсолютно всі
програють від цього. Від того, що почалася ця війна
навколо "Приватбанку", програють абсолютно всі,
в першу чергу українське суспільство.
Тобто пан Коломойський міг і не втратити "Приватбанк"?
Мені важко сказати. Якби держава з ним домовилася,
я думаю, це був би "win-win" і "Приватбанк"
залишився б комерційним, а не державним,
а держава не витрачала б багато грошей,
а Коломойський повертав би борги по своїх підприємствах і так далі.
Як думаєте, довго протримаєтеся на посаді?
Подивимося. Я думаю, що найближчі кілька років будемо працювати.
Якщо будуть якісь речі, які мені не сподобаються,
які тут відбуваються саме  з моральної точки зору,
якщо я побачу, що хтось із команди президента
або прем’єра йде, так би мовити, на поступки
свого сумління, для мене це буде дуже неприємний сигнал.
На такі речі я не зможу піти. Але, на щастя,
тьху-тьху, поки що такого не відбувається.
Дуже дякую.
Дякую вам за інтерв'ю.